from
uc riverside and she'll tell us about
tensor graphical models for complex and
high dimensional data take it away
thank you very much for the kind
introduction
so
i first want to um
thank every uh
the
organizers and the tech support for
making this uh event happen
uh so i first put a title called
gratitude on this picture because it
shows
you know how it's all possible for us to
still talk to each other
at this difficult time
but then i found all the directions on
the picture pawn to the north so i guess
i changed the title to directions but i
guess this is a way to say hi to my
friends in europe and hope
and also other one other people in the
studio hope someday we can talk to each
other in person soon
so the motivation uh for this talk is uh
from
a gene expression data study and the
citation is given uh below by uh the
page at all so in this study they have
some twin pairs and so in their original
study they have both
identical and non-identical twins but we
took the identical twins from the study
and these are called the discordant twin
pairs means they
one of the siblings has a particular
disease called
austeritas
colitis disease and the other twin power
principling is healthy
so the pairing of the data suggests that
the correlation between sample
uh exists in priority and moreover in
many of the experiments there may be
unwanted or unexpected correlations from
the sample for example due to treatment
or due to some other environmental
factors and this is one of the important
uh
aspects in gene expression study as
pointed out by professor
eifron in large scale inference which he
pioneered so we want to use this example
to motivate the high dimensional and the
complex
data part of the talk
and so
first i want to just set up a
mathematical model which is sort of
idealized but can serve as a prototype
to start the conversation about how to
deal with the complex dependency arising
from this type of data so here i model
the data which is a microarray data uh
which is uh you know the sum of two
components one is the mean and one is
the noise so the noise has this complex
structure such that it has both between
sample correlation
as well as the correlation among genes
so those are denoted by b and a so we
have denote the square root of the
correlation among people
and a half denote the correlation among
genes
and then the mean matrix is
deterministic so here with this model
using tubu min means the disease group
has one high dimensional mean vector
and then people from the control group
has shared another common high
dimensional vector beta2
so this is the model we start with
and let's take a look at the this
probability uh probability distribution
of the errors so here
epsilon we model using this
uh you know matrix varied formulation
which i
elaborate below so here we assume z is
some kind of random ensemble so for
throughout this talk i just assume
z is mean zero variance one and has a
set to norm being bounded so the second
norm condition on a scalar just means
the tail of this
random variable
is uh
like a gaussian tail
so we have a formal definition later
and if you just think of z as id uh
gaussian random variable that is enough
to get you started with what's going on
here in the model
so
suppose we can
transform the arrow by b negative half
and then we have this new arrow matrix
which is z times a half
and this is something we feel more
comfortable dealing with uh in
statistics because in statistics
literature we routinely say we have id
sample and this
id means independent identically
distributed so here at least we make our
part independent
and
you know with a small definition on the
z vector we can look at this z a half
as a random
random design which satisfies certain
you know nice conditions to do stressful
inference
so coming back to this uh
this uh
also written collector's data so here
we the reason we model the data such as
previous on the previous slide is
because we assume as mentioned earlier
all the diseased
sample share the same high dimensional
mean vector
and all the healthy group people
share another
high-dimensional mean vector
and then the genes are correlated
uh because they you know gene in the
gene expression study we know they are
controlled by networks you know pathways
and so on so they are currently in that
sense
and then the noise
will be
correlated as well across all the
samples which is kind of an unfortunate
you know aspect of such a study because
we know if the noise is correlated then
you cannot really
ignore those dependency otherwise you
will lose power in terms of student
testing so the starting point of course
is we can
estimate the sample mean which is you
take the sample average for the disease
group and then you take the sample
average for the control group and then
you take this mean out so you sort of
start from there uh assuming the data is
mean zero so of course if that's the
story we can just all go home today and
uh so today i'm going to present you
a much more uh you know
um
complicated story
saying we need to estimate you know the
covariance b
as well as decorate the data so that we
can better control the inference part
when we look at the gene expression data
so here is the high level
uh
technology is we say retrieve each
column vector in this gene expression
data
as a
you know in rn and we want to decorate
so we can model this of course by
writing up a mean which is a
n-dimensional vector and then we write
out the noise as b half times z where z
is isotropic
and now if we can do b negative half in
front of the center data so when i say
center data means i take the mean out
from this high dimensional vector
and then z becomes
uncorrelated so means the covariance of
z is identity matrix of in rn then we
have a similar story as we commonly deal
with that is we have isotropic
uh you know random vectors along each
column for each gene
although along the
you know for each row they are still
correlated because the gene correlation
so put in the matrix form this means we
transform the original data x into y
such that the deterministic part becomes
b negative half times the mean matrix
and then the noise part
is uh
becomes independent of for each column
and so this is a sum of a deterministic
mean component plus a noise which is
isotropic along each gene direction
so we can
uh we can design
estimators to estimate the mean
difference for each gene
as we um already know in the classical
theory is to do
uh or generalize the least square so
means you
look at the transformed
matrix you know which i put in the
bottom so the both d represents this b
negative half b
and then y
is the
transformed data matrix as given here
and the beta hat if i write in the
transform the design and transform the
response then this is just the ordinary
b squared estimator
and
if you put in
all the volt d this
with the expression here you get the
expression for generalized d-square
estimate for each gene of course so far
i only talked about how to estimate this
beta-height uh coordinate by coordinate
then later in the talk i'll talk about
how to do this jointly across the
am genes which is a you know high
dimensional object altogether how do we
select variables from beta head
so the question is of course how do we
estimate b
and so that comes to the next part
of the estimator is suppose we have a b
hat and we will just do plugin so we
replace all the oracle estimator where b
appears with a b-hat which is the
estimated
correlation
covariance matrix among the samples
and then we can again you know estimate
coordinate a coordinate wise beta head
and calculate the mean difference for
each gene and then start to do testing
from this gamma height
downstream
so
for estimating uh so our scale this
slide for now so for estimating b
jointly with a this comes to the tensor
graph model part of the title so the
tensorboard model means
typically when we do graphical model
estimation we assume we are given either
independent rows or independent columns
but for the complex data
oftentimes you have dependency among
both rows and columns and if you have
replicas that you may have dependency
across replicated matrices as well
so as i illustrated in the previous gene
array micro restudy
and so therefore we need to model the
covariance and the inverse differently
from the classical theory so the first
tool we have is to use mutual varied
modeling so assume as i said assuming
the random ensemble c as ib gaussian
then we can write out this as a matrix
normal distribution so mean
in the previous example is this rank 2
object
and then a chronicle b
would represent the covariance
of the microarray data vectorized as a
very long vector of size mn
and so here a
would describe the correlation of
partial correlations
between and among columns and the b
would represent the correlations and the
partial correlations between and among
the rows which are the samples
and the goal is to estimate a and b up
to a certain scalar factor because for
product of two things you cannot
estimate them
up to you know you can only estimate
them up to a scalar factor
so
the conceptual challenges at least when
i first come across this object seems to
be
we have this giant covalence matrix of
size mm by mn you know even you write
how the tensor product you know this
matrix is pretty big and then if you
have only one copy of the data so we
have only
those sample collected from those people
at a certain time
and we have only one sample for this
matrix object
and then you want to do you know
convergence analysis for this large
quantum species using one example this
seems to be pretty
unlikely so at least that was my
impression uh in 2010
and so let's look at the graph
corresponding to a universe and b
inverse and is chronicle product which
is called the
chronicle product of graphs so uh i
guess i will come to like the object in
a couple slides before then i will just
show you
what typically we say about graphic
models as i mentioned earlier is we
assume either have
independent rows or independent columns
and then we want to estimate this sigma
naught and its inverse using those id
sample
and the theta
which we typically call concentration of
precision matrix which is the inverse of
coherence for the gaussian model certain
elements of this theta are assumed to be
zero and we want to use the sum called
the id sample to obtain the set of zeros
as well as the estimator for theta and
sigma given the pattern of zeros so this
is a typical slide i show my talk about
the classical gaussian graphic model
and
in classical gaussian graph model of
course the zeros encode conditional
independence so meaning
if two genes are not connected given the
rest of the graph that means these two
genes are encoded uh un uh independent
given all the other you know genes so
here is a typical
uh you know ar model for type in time
series which shows
every node just connect to two other
nodes
and uh
so depend on the recent past you can
forget about everything happened you
know in the
in the
previous examples
so clearly uh the order of the uh
sparsity is o n rather than
o n squared in this uh example and this
is a star graph
shown in a a paper by ravi kumar at all
uh 2008 and so he was a speaker
yesterday
and the b
has
you know it is a covariance domain is a
full matrix but if you invert it it is
this uh hub spoke
model which again is order
o n and of course i throw in a lot of
other independent random variables to
make this graph look small however even
within this subgraph it is still sparse
so the quantity product of graphs
is a very interesting object
so i believe there are many studies
about this uh object recently in the
computer science literature uh but as
early as uh you know uh
1961 you know there is a theorem which
shows if you
combine you know this uh
uh hub you know there's a hard graph
with signals with a half graph of uh
photos you get a very interesting object
so the left-hand side looks like a you
know a big wheel and the right-hand side
look like a star starfish
so the coordinates of course
just the coordinates from
the vertices of g
and then the vertices of h
so that would represent a coordinate
on the product graph
and then i would appear in its
protograph if
you know
the edges appear in the initial
graphs so for example we can write this
as
g1
g2
originally
belongs to e of g
and then if
h1 h2
belongs to the e
of h
then in the new graph g1
h1
will be adjacent
to g2
and
h2 of course you can read this
connectivity uh description from the
adjacency matrix for corresponding to
the chronicle product of the two
adjacent matrices
for
g and h respectively
and obviously
if you do this
product for three dimensional
graphs so say abc one corresponds to
the
latitude and b correspond to the
longitude and c corresponding to two two
time points and if you want to do a
chronic product of these three
domains then you get a lot of edges as
shown on the right hand side so i'll
keep the left hand side as a riddle
which i will tell you in a minute as i
go through the top
so here is another example of the
complex data so this is a map of the
united states and you can see from the
grid is
you know those are the
coordinates
of the data points they collect from the
one speed data and so this data set
we take the data set from 1948 to
current basically
uh in the last 70 years and then we
extract the wind speed data based on
those uh two
spatial grades so this is we call weston
and this is eastern
and so the western greece you can see
um around here
it is the gulf
and in the middle is the rocky mountain
and then to the left is the pacific
ocean
and it is a highly red reddish area
there are a lot of
rugged mountains and the valleys and so
on
so this is the graph we estimated using
this data set
i'm not going to tell you which model
yet
but you can see
for the
latitude factor it looks like ar2
meaning each neighbor connects not only
to its adjacent node but also you know
the next neighbor
and the longitude graph has a similar
story it also looks like an ar2 but in
the middle it's broken and this
corresponds to the
uh the high
the rocky mountain because we know the
wind is created by the pressure gradient
of the air and then the mountain acts as
a barrier so this shows the
disconnectivity of these two components
and of course those are the
partial correlation graph or the inverse
the precision graph
from this data
and so this is the corresponding graph
we
generated from
the eastern grade and this is largely a
ar1 model except that there is a actual
edge here
and the longitudinal
coordinates also shows ra largely uh
syria uh connectivity ar1 and that with
occasion you know uh ar2 uh
substructures
so n
two is 50 years so this is a for both
graphs this is generated from 50 years
of the historical data in january so in
january we know there's no hurricane
there's no tornado so the east coast the
you know the east
grid in the u.s looks pretty calm
and so here is uh
the model we built we actually used a
cartesian product
to model the entire grid so the
cartesian product is defined as follows
so if you think of this as a
longitudinal and this is the latitude
and
you can give a coordinate
which is a longitude and
latitude coordinate and then
similar to the protograph each new
coordinate in the
cartesian product has two coordinates
which can naturally corresponding to
longitude and the latitude
however the graph is a lot sparser in
that only the two nodes are only
connected if they belong to the same
latitude or if they belong to the same
longitude so for example if i pick
particular
latitude say this is 30
degrees north
and then
i basically see a failure which is
identical to the longitudinal graph and
now if i pick a particular
uh you know
latitude a longitude say 80 degree west
and i look at my favorite fiber which is
just this path corresponding to the
latitude graph we see in the previous
picture
so the cartesian product is a lot
sparser than the
chronicle product graph
and
this is
very attractive in the sense that
uh we can
model some of the conditional dependency
relationships in a passimonious way for
example let's go back to the study of
twins
so suppose i want to study those
features
in childhood so i want to keep
so some so this is a very typical study
in
uh in child development psychology is
they have so many questions to ask about
physical activities and task orientation
or focusedness uh on some you know
specific tasks and
other things like uh you know more
characteristic or temperament like
curiosity openness and of course you
want to keep the
child physically healthy so you keep
track of diet and bmi and so on so
suppose this is the hypothetical graph i
want to build i don't know what edges
look like these edges i put in there are
just based on some you know kind of
conjectures
and now suppose i have another i have a
twin sister and the two of us
participate in the study
so i can imagine the psychologist would
want to ask
the same questions about my sister and
me
how correlated our diets are which is
obviously very correlated and how
correlated our physical activities are
which could be also very correlated
before school age
and
of course they can also ask all these
across questions say
you know how
her activity or her bmi is related to my
uh my diet or her physical activities is
related to my
um you know
openness and so on uh but the point of
using the cartesian product is we just
want to compare
paradise features rather than looking at
all these across edges
so this is just another way of building
the model
for conditional dependence
so the typical but uh so after i work on
these models
i guess the
common thoughts would be
you want to analyze the projections so
the predictions are defined as follows
so suppose i aggregate the data
in these tensor or array or even higher
dimensional you know objects so for
simplicity as i say it's a 3d array
and
so this is me this is my twin
sister
which does not exist
this is a hypothetical and so i want to
study
the you know our childhood development
across
the say four to 20 years so this is the
direction i expose
our data
and i treat all the other data as uh
samples right so i will collect all my
different features and those are called
fabers
i will concatenate with all the fibers
from my transistor
and then i treat this object all
together
as a
um you know as a single matrix and i use
this single matrix to study the
development you know between four to 20
years what is the correlation
and similarly so say those are the
different features right so those can be
our physical activity iq and so on so i
exposed the features and now
all my data
across
you know 4 to 20 years
together with my sister's data from 4 to
20 years uh
serving as sample and we can use those
collect sample to estimate the
correlation between the features
and finally if you want to do study
about the twins so this is me and this
is my
sister and i can do correlation study
using the entire data from me and from
her to look at the raw pearson
correlation coefficient for example and
then you can imagine you have many other
twin sisters or brothers
and then you can compute all these
correlations across people as well
and so this is the initial
motivation why i study the
the matrix varied data is to say say if
you take two columns you compute the
pearson correlation coefficient and you
call it gamma height i j a
so this would corresponding
to you know the raw sample statistic you
want before you do
inverse covariance estimation
and
similarly if i want to estimate b i will
take any two rows
and i compute a pearson correlation
matrix between the two rows so in the
gene expression data this would
correspond into two of the
people in the study
whether they are healthy or not
and the good news is if you do uh
strategic analysis you realize even
though we have a lot of parameters to
estimate all simultaneously
you know they become easier to estimate
as the dimensions and and the m grows so
the correlation coefficients
you know you can estimate them very
accurately
in a sense i will show you in formulas
and
from now on normality is not
needed for the rest of the talk instead
you can just think about you want to
estimate the inverse covariance matrix
and so that was based on a single
example yes uh yeah in the previous
slide could you elaborate a bit more on
like what's happening when n and m are
growing in the sense that
so your
the computational resources you need
that might also increase right so so are
you going to somehow like estimate them
all together so i was just wondering if
you could elaborate a bit more on that
oh yeah that's a very good question so
uh so the correlation i mean the
pairwise correlation computation is easy
right because that's just
you do the inner product so this is a
raw statistical part and then the from
the concentration of measure point of
view you get very sharp concentration
essentially identical to as if you have
id sample of course this is under
self-cautionality assumption on the
whole random ensemble and i will show
you the rate of convergence you know in
a couple slides
and so essentially the proof is based on
hands and write inequality which is
quickly becoming a standard tool in our
field but when i was deriving those
concentration bonds i was using dosing
chaos
and because i was dealing with matrix
normal so i have the tool of gaussian
kills and then a year later
i found the paper by my collaborator
mark rudolson and
and the colleague roman washington on
hands and right for sub gaussian so that
basically makes the whole theory on
which is very normal
to you know eligible for mutual variance
of gaussian
excellent
yeah i will talk about the computational
complexity in a couple of slides thanks
for the question
okay so light was based on a single
random matrix and now suppose i have
replicates and it's the same story as i
draw the picture earlier i just can kind
of concatenate many of the replicates
and expose the feature i want to you
know estimate and construct sample
covariance matrices using the outer
products so in this particular one i'm
constructing the
sample
for those different features the
psychologists may ask me and my twin
sisters about and then for s2 this is
about our developing
years so say from age
2 4 7 9 10 12 basically
in our childhood what is the
developmental correlations across
different years and of course you may
think if you develop a better earlier is
a very good predictor for the later
years and we want to see that from the
data
and so again you expose you know a
direction
such that you use the other direction as
replicates
and so this goes to the very early
estimator which has a rid of a
convergence guarantee for this type of
high dimensional complex data so the
isometer i derived i call it the gemini
so this is basically saying i take the
sample correlation matrix gamma hat a
and gamma hat b i use the graphical
lasso to estimate the panelized
covariance and inverse so if you are
familiar you know the
graph lasso returns you both the
covariance and the inverse estimated
simultaneously so here i just write out
as the sample this is the panelized
uh
correlation matrix and this is the
panelized correlation which is for b and
then you multiply a bunch of weights all
together to construct the final
estimator which you almost never need
because once you have the individual
uh factors and you can just multiply by
the weights you can estimate a skilled
version of a and b
and that's mostly what we need
and so
as you asked earlier what is the rate so
the rate for gamma height a
and for estimating the correlation
coefficient i j of a
is identical to the id case which is
square root n downstairs and upstairs is
square root log
uh a square root of m say if m is larger
than n so i'm just taking the larger of
these two so i'm taking a as the large
of these two covariance matrices
and this c b is some parameter related
to the
matrix the spectral parameters of b
and the key thing to know is this can be
filled if i do a three-step procedure so
three-step procedure basis is the
follows so i
estimate a and b using the two-step
procedure
and after i get b so after i get this
initial estimate of b i can use this b
to decorate my rows to make the rows
become independent very much like what i
did in the very beginning of the talk
when i use the b to decorate the whole
data which contains the mean so the idea
is the same is all the columns becomes
isotropic and i use those isotropic
columns to estimate a i get basically
perfect read of convergence so you
cannot beat this estimate because even
the constant is small is as at most 16
if you kill c of b
so i would be
pretty happy to use such a result and
hand it over to practice
people who who does this type of
analysis
and as a comparison for independent
roles if you indeed have independent
sample
you know this rate is essentially the
same as what is given about
so i will talk about the joint rate of a
and b in the operator norm as a whole
later in the talk but for now i want to
continue the discussion about the
chronicler sum model update and how to
estimate it because i sort of already
gave you a story how to estimate the
chronic product graph and if you trust
me you know the read is pretty nice and
the whole story is almost like
you know a fairy tale and how about the
chronicles sum so the chronic sum uh in
icml paper 2016 uh kaleidosis proposed
the so-called biography lasso estimator
so this isometer basically
want to
minimize the likelihood subject to the
constraint that the omega the precision
matrix has this chronicle some structure
so this chronic sum structure is
basically corresponding to the cartesian
product graph i
draw earlier
and
it also uses this projection idea is to
say i compute the sample coherence
matrices for the rows and for the
columns and i use those as sufficient
statistics to put in my likelihood
function and so once s1 and s2 are
computed i do not need the sample
anymore in this estimator
and instead i solve this likelihood
function
you know subject to the constraint
like
these are both positive
positive definite components so
the penalty is put on individual
precision matrices corresponding to the
row um and the corresponding to the
columns
so this precision matrix in the matrix
form looks like this so you have all
these um you know
diagonal matrices
on the off-diagonal blocks so these are
basically identity matrices so if you
draw schematically those are just sparse
you know identity matrixes and then in
the middle blocks you have those theta
being added
so those are the structure so this is
the structure of a chronicles sum
[Music]
matrix so this slides basically says you
know the big lasso objective is convex
because the log that is a convex
function and the chronic sum is an
unfine operation which i will revisit in
couple slides
and therefore any coordinate descent
algorithm or any gradient you know
composite greeting design type of
algorithms would converge to the global
minimum so in the sample paper
we have a currently descent algorithm
and then
nine uh six years later
with
my former ph.d student christian
greenwald and the collaborator our hero
we published another journal paper uh
you know dealing with the same objective
function but now we allow
the
factors to be
more than two so namely we deal with a
chronicler
a sum
you know a class of matrices such like
you can write out
as follows so for the sake of the talk i
will just use k equal to three so i will
have i one
chronicler i2
chronicle plus i
one so i may have uh you know
screw up the notation
a little bit but the idea
is
the same
so you basically have more block
structures in this covalent smith tree
in this precision matrix and then
similar as before besides estimating
those sample wise and feature wise
covariances by raw covalent matrices you
can also
estimate
the covariance between the
fibers so in my
analogy before it will be this would
compute the correlation between me and
my sister
with our entire history of data as well
as any correlation between me and other
siblings in other twin pairs
so the cartesian product has a very more
nice property as pointed out by the icml
paper is this associativity so here is
an illustration so you may have seen
cartesian product more often than you
realize so for example if i start with a
graph of just a single edge i do a
cartesian product which is itself i get
q2 so q2 is just this square
and now if i do q2
uh cartesian product with a single edge
again i get the q3 which is the three
dimensional cube and now i get if i do
the product of q3 with the pass again i
do not want to you know
make you feel bored i get q4 so
basically those n cubed as the nth power
of k2
with respect to the cartesian product
then why would this be useful so for
example you can imagine this
cube here
which is solid can be used to describe
the spatial temperature and time
correlation for the wind speed
and then this uh you know dotted
hypercube cube can be used to describe
the same you know spatial
temporal uh correlation but for
precipitation and we know the wind speed
and precipitation are created so we can
study them jointly
but also you can collapse them right so
like what we did in the
u.s wind speed study we collapse all the
historical data and use those time
domain as replicates and we just
estimate a two dimensional or two mode
uh
you know product of a cartesian product
of the longitude longitude and the
latitude graphs
okay so
i guess i
talked so far about the quantum sum
precision models
so how many minutes do i have i know it
started a little bit late but i didn't
recall
the starting time
um so maybe five to seven minutes okay
great thank you
okay so uh so let's go back to the
mutual very data without further ado i
just gave you the serum right away so
the theorem basically says i can
estimate each of the coordinates of the
gene
almost perfectly so this is the beta hat
j minus beta j star which corresponding
to the mean
for
the gene j
you know the beta is a
two dimensional vector because one for
the control group one for the diseased
person
and this read is square root log m over
n and we know for high dimensional uh
from high dimensional statistics this is
the optimal rate you can get from the
uh you know gaussian extreme the uh you
know analysis
and then the
operator norm for b
is also
uh you know depends on the
sample size m
and also depends on the number of edges
in the b inverse in the inverse
covariance matrix so
and that there is another factor which
is addition to the mean zero model so in
the gemini mean zero model we only have
this term for the penalty and now
because of the mean estimation we get
this additional term so this is the
matrix our norm from coherence matrix b
and if this is large so this can be
animal square root n our read can
degrade however that is the worst case
estimate for l and r
normally we don't think we have such
high matrix l norm for realistic
applications
and
so
definitely this read is enough for us to
do the analysis for analysis for gis so
this is
sufficiently tight
and
here are some simulation plots so which
shows the residual mean square error for
estimating the beta indeed goes down for
different topologies and for different
configurations of the sample size and
the dimension of a and b so we treat you
know we look at a as a ar model and b a
as an erdos ringing random graph or a
star block model and so on so the
average for venus norm arrow also goes
down as an and and
increases as i forecasted in the
beginning of the top
so here is the algorithm so as i said in
the beginning we can just do sample mean
so that's the starting point we take the
sample our average of observed
you know red vectors and this is the
sample average of the blue vectors from
the control group and we take those
out from each individual according to
its group so this is a labeled sample so
we know which person has the disease
which person doesn't
and after so in statistics we call this
the centering so this is the center of
the data now a roughly is mean zero and
we compute the gamma height and b as i
showed earlier using the pearson
correlation coefficient calculation
and i put in the graph lasso estimators
and with the appropriate penalty adding
this additional term because the mean
estimation
and then i construct rescale to estimate
b because i need this object to put in
my gis estimator
and absolutely we do not care about the
scale because you can see there is a
inverse and there's a inverse and
there's a inverse so with all the
inverse cancellation the skill doesn't
matter if there is a scalar factor it
will all disappear so we only need to
estimate b up to a certain
positive scale
factor
and finally to do inference you need to
calculate the test statistic and
upstairs is from what we estimated using
the gis and downstairs is a plug-in
estimate for the standard deviation for
this gamma height statistic for each
coordinate
and so the second algorithm we do is to
say okay if we estimated
gamma hat using the gis if we believe
that's a better estimate of the mean why
don't we do the following
so
for certain
you know genes we know they are not
differentially expressed so if they are
below the threshold we just do global
centering means we just take the mean of
all the sample out rather than based on
the group so on the
uh on the top right gene according to
gamma hat
you know magnitude
we
center the data based on the control of
the disease group
and the reason we want to do this is
because we believe you know if you
center those part of the data you can
bring in arbitrary noise unnecessarily
so if so we send the data slightly more
carefully and then redo the whole
algorithm we re-estimate b hat and so on
so indeed this gives us very good
estimate and for the time
concern i'm not going to go to the
simulations but here is the outcome for
this uh
uh you know
also returns collateral data
so as you can see we estimated
those inverse correlation based on the
panelized method
and you can see all these blocks shows
all the most of the twins still show
correlation
and this is perhaps uh more you know
more visible when i show you the graphs
and then you can see some pairs sometime
pairs are highly correlated and some are
not and some of the unquality unrelated
people seem to be partitive
so
if i look at the penalty and if i
increase the penalty 2.6 i think that's
pretty high and for the pairs who
survive this high penalty we can see
those vertical lines are between the
siblings
and then there are some actual edges
between and among the diseased people
and more curiously so if we look at this
one when we have the penalty point 65
which is pretty high we see those three
people
with the disease one seven and nine they
are connected so just before i give this
talk i look up the original paper in the
play uh the page uh so if our label is
the same as their label in the paper
then
it shows these three people are on some
kind of
steroid
treatment so this can cause unexpected
sample correlation in the study
as a warrant by
by firm
so
we can also do this iteratively since we
did it twice we can do it 10 times and
every time we can rank the top 10 genes
to see which are relevant
and this is more like just try to see
how much noise can propagate throughout
the algorithm and so in the end we see
three genes you know persisted among the
top ranked 10 genes throughout this
iteration and we reported those three
genes in our paper so one of the genes
is clearly related to
uh to gastric and
colon uh colon cancer type of uh you
know uh uh
so in the literature those are related
uh reported be related to compressor uh
diagnosis and so on so that says our
algorithm is able to uncover the signal
despite the
uh you know the
uh the on the cardiac noise so i often
was asked about the whole
uh you know arrow for us making the a
chronicle b as a whole because in the
previous theorem i only care about b so
i only reported live and so this is the
theorem i proved in back in 2014 so this
is saying if you want to ask me the
whole matrix chronicle product you get
the sum of these two terms one
corresponding to estimate
a and one correspond to estimation arrow
of b
and you sum them up that is the arrow
for estimating the whole chronic product
and so if you are familiar with the
randomization theory this is a saying in
the classical bin law where we have
those you know a dimension of n o m or m
over n inside the square root
those are replaced by the corresponding
sparsity um
you know parameters
and these two summons corresponding to
the convergence risk for estimate a and
b
as i mentioned already so in summary the
high dimensional setting requires us to
consider the component of gamma as well
as the inverse
b
among samples jointly
because if we have two samples if you
have two replicates of the study let's
definitely make the whole thing trivial
because from elementary studies you know
the difference of two random variables
from the same distribution has mean zero
and the variance doubled and so you just
need to do the subtraction of these two
to isometric coverage and then you do
decoration so that tells you why the
single sample case is very challenging
on the other hand
and so even with very simple to
sample mean clustering centering scheme
as a starting point we improve the
estimation essentially make it uh
efficient from the classical theory
on gis
and so one can that definitely replace
the
estimator
with a node-wise regression for example
and get even sharper rates of
convergence so in some of my ongoing
work i'm
exploring this you know method for the
mutual validator also under missing
values
so i will escape the whole theory
on the cancer
chronicles sum because of the lack of
time so in conclusion
in this talk i showed that complex data
sets can activate partial correlations
between both features and instances
and the associativity of the control sum
use an approach for modeling data sets
organized into three or higher order
tensors
and we analyze this classical method gis
in the highly medical setting where we
need to jointly estimate the mean and
the covariance and normality is never
needed thanks to the hands and writing
inequality and we consider the
subgaussian ensembles and direct height
concentration measure bounds throughout
the you know uh the the top so
thank you very much
and here is a picture i liked because
this shows our coordinates in space
uh longitudinally and i
so with that i conclude my top i'm happy
to
answer any questions you may have
thanks so much professor joe questions
hi
very nice talk
very inspiring works uh i have two
questions
first of all in order to achieve the
risk rate you have may ask the sample
size requirement
to say that how many samples what's the
end requirement to make
the estimation possible
uh which one which model
yeah all models
okay so for the
for the chronic product you can estimate
with the sample size n equal to one
because you can make different type of
assumptions for example you can say
uh you know a inverse sparsely is
bounded by n and b inverse obviously so
the b is the smaller one it can be
easily bounded by m
so this is saying if you just make
assumption on sparsely alone you can
assume you're estimating a subgraph uh
you know a graph a
matrix a with a lot of sub components
which are destroyed but you can replace
assumptions by some other
assumptions for example as i said here
in my original paper i actually used
a result from
kai at all to
so this paper
and you know to make different type of
assumptions on the covariance a and b to
derive even tighter bounds
and then if you use a node-wise
regression your
you know your rate will depend on the
maximum node degree rather than the
total number of nodes so that is sort of
my ongoing work but in the context of
missing values so that is for chronic
product you can start convergence with n
equal to one
and then the one i didn't get to talk to
today about the chronicle sum
is it's a lot harder to get the sample
size n equal to one so this is the serum
i proved after our paper
uh you know was published with christian
greenwald and our hero
but this is basically saying if you want
to prove a uh you know just a no
replicated result for the chronicles
model
essentially you you need your data to be
well organized in the sense that no
dimension is going to dominate the rest
of the dimensions
you know
the product of the the other dimensions
so for example this one is an extreme
it's saying if we have a very large
dimension along b1 which is square root
p and then all the other dimensions the
product of all the other d2 and so on is
also square root p so then this
component would be this is something up
here in the binding law which is the
nominal dimension versus the
the nominal sample size this would you
know become a constant then you will
have a hard time converging to zero for
a single replicate so unfortunately i
didn't get to talk about this today
but indeed you can make assumptions and
make an equal one work even for the
chronicles model
thank you very much yeah follow up
question for that yeah i can't
understand if the matrix is of a square
shape
so it means that you understand to a to
investigate the row wise covariance we
actually have
unsamples instead of one sample the
number of columns of samples
now imagine if the matrix is very for
example very thin
say shape
the number of columns is much more than
the number of rows
and then to estimate the
the b matrix you have
you only have a limited number of
samples a number of rows
but you will have a very very high
dimensional
objects but in that case would your
result be different
can we still estimate
a and b
if we only have one sample
uh you mean
for quantum product or sum yeah chronic
product okay so for chronic product if
uh
one dimension is really low
um
and it depends on
if you want to estimate the diagonal or
not
right because if you need to estimate
the diagonal
of the other dimension
um
i i guess it depends on whether you want
to estimate the factor or not
so uh so this result basically shows
um
you need the the n to be
at least as large
you know
of the log right the log term so n needs
to be at least the square root log of m
and also you need to dominate the number
of edges in the other graph
so i guess if b is really
um so if a is really simple then we just
go back to the
classical result right
so if it is really simple closely
identity matrix
then whatever sample constraints we have
in the id case would apply to that case
at least that would be my intuition
now i can see from your bound we need n
to be greater than
equal to sparsity times a log term so i
think that's right so this long term
is unavoidable at least i didn't work to
make it go away
because i thought at least this is
very typical in high dimensional
statistics
okay i understand uh one more just a
quick question so there are you proposed
as a serial models um to model this
let's say matrix random sample
and which one should we choose in
practice can you give us some guideline
well that's a very good question so
actually when i talk about this u.s
grade
i would want people to put in the world
in the chat do you think that
geographical you know uh you know um
the spatial uh correlation matrix or
partial correlation which you do think
they should be a product or a sum
so i i know there are you know people
are probably not able to do chat right
now
but i think it really
depends on
the
contact we have so for me
it looks like in this geographical
setting chronicles some is a pretty
attractive because
first of all it's a non-separable model
and i know in spatial temporal domain
people have a lot of agony against the
chronicle product
but chronicle product as you can see
from the theory
it is slightly
easier to estimate
uh
probably precisely because of the
separability uh you know uh
like a
representation so i feel
if you don't know your data type if you
just want to try something out chronicle
product is a pretty good starting point
and then you can refine your estimate to
say what would happen if i try the
chronicle sum
as well and obviously the sum is more or
less like a subgraph of the chronicle
product so it's almost like if you have
a dense graph how do you trim it off so
that you get the parsimonious model to
explain your data so it's almost like uh
in in that sense i think corner sum is
more sophisticated on model
thank you that makes sense
i know i'm on recording so i am a bit
hesitant to make the such predictions
but indeed i feel the chronic sound is
probably going to be very useful in the
spatial temporal domain uh but chronic
product as always it's like a a very old
friend of mine and i always like to try
it out on the real data to see how that
tells me about the story of the sample
correlations
thanks so much professor joe so in the
interest of time i'm probably going to
close the questioning session uh and
we're going to
resume at 3 25 let's stand professor joe
again